[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les matins du
cdh a un droit de réponse le président
de l'association musulmane pour un islam
de france a été auditionné par la
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste
il souhaitait réagir aux propos de la
journaliste zineb el rhazoui zineb el
rhazoui qui devant cette même commission
denquête avait estimé que l'association
musulmane pour un islam de france était
je cite un clergé adoubé par la
république qui pourra émettre des fatwas
on regarde l'audition on en reparle
juste après notre peau ici pas de
répondre aux polémiques qui sont qui
font partie du jeu notamment quand on
parle d'islam en france c'est un sujet
qui est assez fertile en polémique notre
propos c'est vous expliquer comment
concrètement on pense qu'on peut agir
cette réflexion s'inscrit dans un cadre
enfin dans ce fruit de quatre ans de
travail que j'ai commencé moi
personnellement avec l'institut
montaigne qui ont donné lieu à deux
rapports je voulais mon train il y en a
un qui s'appelle un islam français est
possible un autre qui s'appelle la
fabrique de l'islamisme je crois
d'ailleurs que monsieur bigon a demandé
à ce que l'institut soit auditionné pour
qu'on vous parle
dans le détail de ces travaux est
personnellement peut-être pour commencer
pourquoi je suis là pour quoi je
travaille là dessus
pour moi le choc c'était charlie c'était
charlie c'est l hyper cacher avec une
question je suis français confession
musulmane de double culture ma mère et
les protestante j'ai été élevé dans dans
cette double tradition toujours
considéré que la religion était quand
même plutôt une affaire privée j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur les questions de
diversité j'ai créé le club du 21e
siècle
j'étais conseiller de jean-pierre
raffarin puis ensuite banquier chez
rothschild
je me suis dit ce jour là qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire et surtout est-ce qu'on
peut ne rien faire quand quelqu'un comme
moi quelqu'un comme nous qu'ils ont
bénéficiez de l'école de la république
qui ont été élevés socialiser dans ce
contexte là est ce qu'on peut dire
finalement la religion c'est une affaire
privée
ça ne nous regarde pas c'est sûr lui
berlue
c'est dangereux ces terroristes est pour
moi la réponse a été non il faut agir
certaine manière malgré soi parce que la
plus grande pente vous portent plutôt
dans le respect de la tradition laïque
on peut discuter de ce que c'est que la
tradition laïque mais à considérer
qu'aujourd'hui les questions religieuses
sont des questions privées je pense
et notamment la question musulmane n'est
plus une question privée mais est devenu
une question politique certaine manière
cette commission tous les travaux toutes
les inquiétudes qu'il ya autour de
l'islam en témoigne et donc je me suis
dit il faut essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe pour agir
comprendre ce qui se passe ça a donné ça
a donné ce premier travail et et
notamment une grande enquête sur les
musulmans parce que on parle toujours
des musulmans 1
mais on ne sait pas qu'il soit en
général d'ailleurs on leur donne assez
peu la parole on parle pour eux et nous
ce qu'on a essayé de faire avec
l'institut montaigne
c'est à la fois comprendre les
dynamiques mais faire une photographie
faire un diagnostic avant donner une
stratégie avant de proposer une
politique je pense c'est toujours mieux
de savoir de quoi on parle
ce diagnostic qu'est ce qu'il a montré
il à montrer l'extraordinaire diversité
de la situation avec une population
beaucoup plus jeune que le reste de la
population française très forte
concentration géographique liée en fait
c'est la géographie la reconstruction de
la france et la géographie l'immigration
on a vu aussi une une diversité sociale
assez inattendu il ya un cliché sur
l'échec du modèle français d'intégration
cette enquête montrent qu'il n'y a pas
d'échec du modèle français d'intégration
il ya des échecs d'intégration qu'ils
sont minoritaires
ce que ça montre aussi c'est que à
situation égale de départ le destin
sociale des immigrés plutôt meilleur que
celui du reste de la population
française ce que ça montre c'est que il
ya une élite
il ya une classe moyenne aujourd'hui
de confession musulmane inattendue parce
qu'invisible parce que silencieuse et je
vais revenir sur ce silence
ce que ça montre et ça on le sait c'est
qu'il ya un échec de l'intégration qu'on
mesure assez bien à travers le nombre de
personnes qui sont hors de l'emploi hors
des institutions on a mesuré dans cette
enquête 30 % 30 % des musulmans
on va les appeler musulmans ge pour
faire simple je devrais dire français de
confession musulmane ou de culture
puisqu'ils ne sont pas tous musulmans
quand bien même ils seraient de culture
musulmane qui sont à l'écart là dedans
il ya des femmes qui ne travaillent pas
et puis il ya de nombreux jeunes ce
qu'on a vu et d'une certaine manière à
ma grande surprise parce que je savais
que ça existait je pensais pas que le
quantum était aussi important c'est que
on a la majorité de la population des
français comme les autres
intégrer républicains plus croyant que
la majorité des français qui ont un
système de valeurs qui ressemble assez à
celui des catholiques pratiquants plus
conservateurs sur le plan des moeurs qui
tient exactement les mêmes relations aux
impôts à l'immigration et c'est ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il ya un deuxième groupe
un quart à peu près avec beaucoup
d'étrangers donc d'immigrés de première
génération qui à l'évidence importe
leurs us et coutumes de leur pays
d'origine mais qui ne revendique pas qui
en gros pense qu'ils pensent mais mais
qui ne l'affichent pas ne l'affirment
pas n'ont pas de vision autoritaire dans
l'espace public et puis il ya un
troisième groupe qui est le plus
problématique où il ya beaucoup de
jeunes énormément de jeunes ou là à
l'évidence on a des français parce
qu'ils sont tous français cela qui
utilisent la religion pour manifester
une forme de rébellion on parlait dans
le rapport de sécession sécession
idéologique qui veut pas dire violence
mais ce qui veut dire inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes et c'est très
important autoritarisme vision
autoritaire de la religion et vision
autoritaire de la religion à l'égard
d'abord de leurs coreligionnaires
je rappelle c'est très important que les
premières cibles des islamistes ce sont
les musulmans
ça c'était le constat on peut parler des
raisons vous avez auditionné beaucoup de
gens très compétents
je vais pas je vais pas m'étendre dessus
maintenant les solutions une fois qu'on
a dit ça qu'est ce qu'on voit et puis
quand on a complété ce travail là avec
celui là qui retrace la généalogie la
fabrication industrielle de l'islamisme
depuis en gros un siècle avec quatre
centres le centre égyptien des frères
musulmans
le centre saoudiens ou arbitres seraient
et mezza voce d'une certaine manière le
centre iranien et puis aujourd'hui quand
même très fort le centre turc
qu'est-ce que ça monte ça monte qui lie
à une offensive idéologique
je suis bien idéologique pas religieuse
pour affirmer affiché prend le pouvoir
édicter une certaine vision de l'islam
l'imposer aux musulmans et dire au reste
du monde c'est ça l'islam fois qu'on a
dit ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait un on
reconnaît que c'est un grand combat
d'idées
c'est un grand combat idéologique c'est
un grand combat théologique et c'est
important de le considérer ce n'est pas
un problème social ça à faire avec dieu
ça à faire avec la religion pourquoi
c'est important parce que toutes mes
discussions avec les parties prenantes
publiques me montrent que c'est
compliqué et c'est encore compliqué
peut-être moins aujourd'hui qu'il ya
deux ou trois ans pour de reconnaître
que c'est un problème religieux dans un
état qui est un état laïc qui a du mal à
comprendre parfois qui a oublié ce que
pouvait être la rue dieu la religion
donc c'est un sujet religieux c'est un
sujet religieux d'abord à l'intérieur de
l'islam avec la volonté des uns
d'imposer leur vision et à travers leur
vision religieuse leur vision de
l'organisation de la société
leur vision des relations entre les
sexes notamment une organisation dans
les familles et
la vision de l'organisation politique et
puis du coup c'est aussi un sujet entre
eux les islamistes et la république
parce que certaine manière c'est un
projet concurrent
et quand ils viennent et quand ils
prêchent qu'est ce qu'ils disent ils
disent regardez vous les jeunes français
on vous dénie votre francité regardez le
niveau discrimination regardez comment
vous êtes traité
regardez les différences qu'il ya entre
vous et les autres et puis regardez
aussi vos parents vos parents ont été
humiliés vos parents ont été colonisés
et puis d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas dans
votre pays d'origine que c'est quoi
votre identité et notre identité c'est
musulmans mais pas musulman comme aux
parents aux parents les ont été humiliés
musulmans comme nous on vous le dit avec
une affirmation identitaire avec une
affirmation politique c'est pour ça
qu'il faut parler je crois d'islam fade
et des identitaires musulmans qui
veulent s'affirmer qui veulent
s'afficher avec une hiérarchie des
normes qui est remise en cause très très
très clairement
bon une fois qu'on a fait ce constat qui
est inquiétant compte tenu notamment des
volumes
qu'est ce qu'on fait ben on considère
qu'il faut mener une bataille que cette
bataille
je le dis je pense que c'est important
elle se gagnera pas sans les musulmans
elle se gagnera pas sans la mobilisation
des musulmans
elle se gagnera pas sans quels pouvoirs
publics inclut les musulmans dans leur
réflexion
bien souvent on a des réflexions de
l'exécutif au départ ou des
parlementaires enfin peu importe on voit
tout le monde sauf les musulmans non
c'est une bataille qui se joue à
l'intérieur de l'islam et qui se gagnera
avec les musulmans qui se perdra sans
les musulmans donc il faut mobiliser les
musulmans ensuite il faut parler aux
musulmans comment on fait on peut parler
institutions ses 20 ans de discussions
le cfcm la représentativité et c'est
nous notre idée c'était que la question
de la représentation est une impasse
c'est très compliqué par scarpelli pas
légitime en islam
et puis quand vous allez parler aux gens
qui finalement nous intéresse e
plus vous êtes institutionnelle plus
vous êtes représentatif - vous êtes
légitime pour eux et donc notre idée a
été d'aller sur le nerf de la guerre
nerf de la guerre c'est quoi c'est
l'argent la régulation il ya des marchés
aujourd'hui liées à l'islam et à le
marché du halal dont on parle beaucoup
il ya le marché du pèlerinage juin dont
on parle très peu mais qui est le plus
important qui est celui des dons et les
gens les fidèles les français les
français comme les autres les
consommateurs savent que tout ça est
extraordinairement mal organisés avec
formes de prévarication d1 une forme de
d'absence de qualité du service des
autres des prix trop élevés presque tout
le temps et c'est pourquoi pourquoi
parler de ça parce que il faut pouvoir
rendre des services
dans un contexte où
l'institutionnalisation et compliqué il
faut d'une certaine manière faire de la
politique par la preuve
je cite quelqu'un d'autre la preuve
c'est qu'on est capable de rendre un
service qui est un service nécessaire
l'idée de l'amif c'est ça c'est un
régulateur qui rend des services et qui
en échange collecte un petit peu
d'argent et qui utilisent cet argent non
pas pour le privatiser
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais pour
le socialiser le mettre au service de
l'intérêt général
le service de l'intérêt général ou
aujourd'hui c'est quoi bah je vous dis
il ya un grand combat idéologique il
faut financer des chaires pas forcément
des chaires de recherche publique mais
le travail théologique c'est extrêmement
important c'est la mère de toutes les
batailles
il faut former des religieux avec autre
chose que la vulgate traditionnel qui
est pas forcément extrémisme et
traditionalistes ou traditionnistes qui
consiste à répéter je parle sous
l'autorité du professeur magera fil des
interprétations on va dire pour le moins
anciennes il faut aussi donner des
moyens pour salarier les humains parce
que former des imams si on n'est pas
capable de les payer ça sert à rien et
aujourd'hui on est capable à peu près de
former des imams plus ou moins bien on
est incapables de les payer
il faut aussi c'est absolument essentiel
être présent sur les réseaux sociaux
tout le monde
regarde de très près ce qui se passe
dans les mosquées l'enjeu est beaucoup
plus sur les réseaux sociaux que dans
les mosquées dans la quête qu'on avait
fait on avait demandé aux musulmans ou
est ce que vous apprenez ou est-ce que
vous transmettez islam la première
réponse était la famille la deuxième
c'était google et la mosquée arrivé bien
bien bien après donc il ya cette
question du combat théologique assumer
qu'il faut pouvoir financer et puis il
ya l'inscription l'islam dans la société
il faut pas laisser le combat contre la
haine anti musulmane aux identitaires il
faut s'en emparer et si possible
d'ailleurs pas la réduire à la question
musulmane
moi je rêve d'aller souhaite
universalisme et pas d'un combat
antiraciste fragmentaires il faut
absolument se saisir de la question de
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme au nom
de l'islam il existe sert à rien de se
cacher derrière son petit doigt
il faut le combattre et une organisation
musulmane a vocation à le combattre
et puis enfin et peut-être surtout le
djihadisme le djihadisme a une dimension
religieuse le djihadisme doit être
combattu avec des arguments religieux et
je pense c'est essentiel pour l'ensemble
de la communauté nationale l'ensemble
des français de voir qu'une organisation
musulmane s'engage sur ce sujet donc
voilà à quoi sert la mif à la fois un
collecteur qui organise qui régule kim
et du professionnalisme et qui utilisent
les fonds collectés pour former pour
mener la comble la bataille idéologique
et pour également inscrire l'islam dans
les questions de société et lutter
contre les ennemis qu'il faut combattre
tout d'abord merci beaucoup de votre
invitation qui nous permet de pouvoir
exposer
je n'ose pas dire notre point de vue
mais une certaine réalité qui est la
nôtre
j'aime beaucoup cette maison là mon père
était sénateur d'afrique du nord dans
les suites il a participé au siècle
dernier à la première organisation du
culte
seulement en france moi même j'étais
intéressé par ces questions parfois été
nommé en 98 par le président chirac
membre du comité national d'éthique au
titre des décès des cinq personnes
désignées directement par un large
public en raison de leur appartenance à
un courant de pensée philosophique ou
spirituelle
ça peut étonner dans une république
démocratique laïque et social
il se trouve qu'on se trouve un
catholique un protestant et musulman
votre serviteur un juif et un libre
penseur c'est par hasard parce qu'on
aurait pu avoir très bien 5,5 bouddhiste
cette espèce de hasard cette espèce de
laïcité bien comprise et qui permet
finalement de suivre exactement la
première devise américaine est plus
riboud ce coup nous sommes arrivés à
faire un avec plusieurs et pour lutter
contre la juxtaposition de communautés
dont nous ne voulons pas ça m'a mené la
présidente du conseil d'orientation de
l'agencé de la biomédecine qui étaient
des choses que le comité d'éthique et de
manière plus appliqués puisqu'on était
en charge d'assurer finalement l'équité
de la distribution des organes et des
allocations dans ma table 2 tentation
mais aussi de donner l'autorisation du
régime d'autorisation ceux des
recherches sur les cellules souches sont
des cellules embryonnaires sur la partie
de greffe d'organes une très bref 1,6
vous savez très bien qu'on n'a pas le
droit et c'est heureux en france de
faire de statistiques ethniques ou
confessionnelles et on peut se demander
est ce que nos concitoyens de confession
musulmane
est-ce qu'ils vont s que des familles
vont accepter d'être donneuse d'organes
au même titre que les autres que les
autres religions et la république ne
peut pas faire ça puisque l'idée que ne
reconnaît aucun aucun culte
de manière intéressante sont des
statistiques uniquement au doigt mouillé
c'est un travail simplement de médecins
et puis d'impression lorsque j'étais
étudiant en médecine lorsque j'étais
jeune interne le le pourcentage de dons
d'organes par rapport à des personnes
qui sont en état de mort encéphalique et
qui sont de confession musulmane ce
pourcentage était de 0 % au fil du temps
maintenant dans madame anne thomas
pratique trente ans plus tard ben je
rends compte que la moyenne nationale
c'est elle et elle est aux alentours de
30% le taux de refus c'est les personnes
de confession musulmane la famille va se
faire témoin d'une
édition d'à peu près 50% des cas donc
c'est un verre à moitié vide ou à moitié
plein moi je pense à comme une logique
d'intégration heureuse pardon des
stimulations puisqu'elle que seule
communauté qui valent qui est là qui est
de la communauté nationale
finalement pourquoi est-ce que la miss
pourquoi est-ce que lorsque hakim
d'autres amis me demander ce que je
souscris complètement à ce à ce projet
je dois dire comme déclarations de liens
d'intérêts fin de conflit d'intérêts de
liens d'intérêts que je suis aussi un
membre du bureau du conseil français du
culte musulman dont j'ai rien contre le
cfcm au contraire et que je suis aussi
président du conseil d'orientation de la
fondation de l'islam de france qui a une
vocation culturelle et donc vous savez
qu'elle a été au départ initié porté par
le président chevènement finalement
l'idée c'était de pouvoir être au
service de tous être au service de tous
ces musulmans et et non et non musulmans
pour tous les français pardon pour les
croyants et pour dénombrer et pour des
non croyants
parce qu'on voit bien que ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui est quelque chose qui
est d'essence je crois très importante
la question de l'islam en france est une
des quatre cinq grandes questions que
notre pays doit affronter mature et et
puis finalement dépasser pour pouvoir
être présents pouvant être présents de
manière sereine entre nous et aussi à
l'échelon international
paris est symboliquement une forme de
capital du monde arabe musulman et
chrétien et au delà des partis des deux
c'est parti linguistique
quand on est de bonne famille en egypte
au liban et bien les garçons ils vont
apprend et des garçons ils vont à
l'université américaine pour apprendre
le business et puis l'anglais et puis
les filles vont universités françaises
pour apprendre les bonnes moeurs et les
bonnes manières parce que tout ce beau
monde là je suis très sexiste et
peut-être outrecuidant je dis que c'est
un élément passé dans cet imaginaire
symbolique qui est celui-là de cette
belle société qui est absolument
trilingue français anglais arabe
il a une dimension qui fait que paris ça
apparaît symboliquement comme la
capitale du monde du monde arabe
un premier ministre avait émis une fois
une vocation de faire de paris une
espèce de harvard de l'islam on est dans
cette dimension là je pense que n'ayant
pas peur mais il y en n'ayant pas peur
de notre vocation internationale ou
internationaliste et soyons cette espèce
de vrai far et c'est vrai que si on
prend les grandes institutions que nous
avons dans notre pays il ya le conseil
français du culte musulman qui a une
vocation ordinale c'est quasiment notre
ordre des médecins ou andres des avocats
des architectes déjà que le conseil
français du culte musulman mais
finalement il va pouvoir déclarer que
telle ou telle à la vocation ou à la
potentialité pour être imam ça veut dire
qu'ils leur disent y avoir une un
pouvoir de police lorsqu'un imams se
comporte de manière absolument dévoyé en
tant que si vous écoutez de la musique
vous allez devenir un chien ou encore
pire rapport on va pouvoir avoir un
élément de sanction
à côté il ya un élément finalement de
sécularisation procède pour cette
majorité
et puis la fondation dizaines de france
qui a une vocation culturelle n'est
peut-être pas importante au plan
quantitatif des très importantes au plan
qualitatif
parce que c'est le dialogue avec ses
autres partis république année au dg
pour ça que je pense que cet élément là
peut être fédérateur et utile pour tous
merci d'abord merci pour l'invitation
très rapidement pourquoi le projet de
l'ami fait pourquoi l'avoir rejoint jeu
reviendrait exactement sur le départ que
mes deux coauteurs ont mentionné à
savoir ce qui s'est passé en janvier
jusque là je savais ont mené en interne
un combat contre une idéologie
extrémiste qui a la particularité et
vous me direz c'est le cas de toute
idéologie extrémiste de vouloir mettre
de vouloir faire main basse sur l'islam
et quand en 2015 en janvier 2015 ont eu
lieu les attentats
j'ai dû personnellement sur proposition
d'un éditeur commencé à écrire et j'ai
commis un un livre en 2015 que j'avais
intitulé l'islam de france là un partant
de l'idée que on souffre nous à
l'intérieur de l'islam d'une sorte de
statisme qui pour beaucoup en pêche de
pouvoir dire que nous ne pouvons pas et
c'est une phrase que je répète souvent
lire le monde d'aujourd'hui avec les
lunettes de gens qui nous ont précédés
il ya par exemple milan et que par
conséquent on ne peut par exemple pas
dire je vous le dis ici tout autant que
je le dis ailleurs que le terrorisme n'a
rien à voir avec une certaine lecture de
l'islam
ce que je vous dis là je le dis devant
dans les mosquées de france et de
navarre en disant clairement que le
terrorisme peut trouver de quoi le
justifier dans l'héritage juridique de
l'islam et à partir de là un travail
s'impose qui est un travail de mon point
de vue de déconstruction de montrer
qu'il existe une autre lecture que celle
là qui est proposé autant ancienne que
nouvelle et que par conséquent pour
aller très rapidement au but
il est du devoir du musulman sous peine
de voir sa religion
non seulement est très de voiliers mais
aussi et surtout clairement et
simplement disparaître et bien de se
ressaisir de cet effort d'interprétation
qui est cher à l'islam qu'on appelle ici
tirade afin justement est bien de
permettre pour parler du cas
d'école qui est le nôtre le cas français
aux musulmans aux français de confession
musulmane de vivre à la fois son
islamité et sa francité étant convaincu
que les deux n'étaient pas antinomiques
parti de là trois ans après j'ai commis
un autre livre intitulé lettre à un
jeune français musulmans réveillons nous
avec toujours le même objectif
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour aller
très vite c'est qu' il existe deux pans
qui en réalité de mon point de vue
monopolise les débats dans cette affaire
pour tout ce qui est à voir avec l'islam
en tout cas en france c'est que d'un
côté nous avons cette lecture
littéraliste et extrémistes curit
puristes pour pour laquelle il n'existe
pas une autre forme de vivre l'islam que
la sienne et puis de l'autre côté vous
avez une lecture non moins radicale et
extrémiste pour laquelle il n'existe
qu'une seule et unique forme de lire le
texte coranique par exemple qui est
celle des extrémistes et du coup on se
retrouve
nous au milieu par la majorité des
musulmans que l'on sommes permanemment
est constamment de devoir dire je ne
suis pas ceci je ne suis pas cela alors
que comme il a été dit ici à plusieurs
reprises la majorité des musulmans des
français de confession musulmane vivent
en parfaite harmonie avec les lois de la
république et la plupart du temps ne
pose aucun problème
mais vous savez que c'est une c'est une
manie chez nous on parle souvent des
trains qui arrivent en retard d'avoir
davantage que ceux qui arrivent à
l'heure et quand on vient en tenir un
discours de réconciliation comme dit un
ami il faut accepter que on est un trait
d'union et qu'en tant que trait d'union
on doit se faire taper des deux côtés
alors d'un côté on nous traite de vendu
à la république et de l'autre avec des
menaces qui les menace qui vont avec
et puis de l'autre on nous traite de
cinquième colonne et on est ainsi comme
cela mais c'est justement parce que nous
avons cette ambition de réconciliation
chevillée au corps que nous nous sommes
engagés dedans au mépris parfois de
menaces qui nous concerne
personnellement des
menaces de mort mais dont je préfère ne
pas faire mention ici qui viennent de
côté bien précis dont on parlera c'est
bien entendu les questions nous y
conduisent donc adhéré à cette à cette
idée de à ce projet de l'amif s'inscrit
pleinement dans ce combat que nous
menons au quotidien parce que nous
restons quand même des acteurs de
terrain
j'ai les vendredis à peu près entre 2500
à 5000 personnes qui écoutent un prêche
il ya on essaye avec les moyens qui sont
les nôtres de diffuser un discours qui
soit en opposition avec cette manière
j'ai envie de dire littéraliste et
extrémiste de voir les choses et j'ai
découvert dernièrement avec satisfaction
que les vidéos que nous faisons de
manière très artisanale ce que j'ai pas
une équipe derrière qui me gère j'ai des
étudiants à moi qu'ils ont c'est eux qui
ont décidé de mettre les cours sur
internet moi j'ai jamais mis de cours
sur internet
apparemment elle totaliserait à peu près
entre 12 millions à 20 millions de vues
alors je me dis c'est peut-être quelque
chose qui mériterait que l'on continue
mais je vous avouerai que parfois on a
envie de baisser les bras tellement les
tensions sont fortes
d'un côté comme de l'autre je vous
remercie encore pour votre merci
messieurs tout d'abord monsieur el
karoui de vous rassurer nous
auditionneront l'institut montaigne en
tant que tel les travaux de cet institut
nous intéresse alors vous parlez d'un
islam modéré
donc en creux cela met en exergue un
islam radical qui justifie le concept
d'après vous de l'islam de france
alors qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un
judaïsme de france où un catholicisme de
france où un bouddhisme de france
donc pour nous prémunir vous
vous avez effectivement créé avec
plusieurs personnes certaines identifié
comme à un moment de leur parcours comme
frères musulmans mais ça je laisserai la
rapporteure en parler plus précisément
donc vous créer une association ou
plutôt de une association loi 1901 que
vous présidez est une association 1905
que monsieur tarek au groupe réside
alors je voudrais savoir comment s'est
passée cette est ce que c'est une
nomination parce que aujourd'hui c'est
une constitution ou une élection vous
avez combien d'adhérents aujourd'hui
dans votre association quels sont les
statuts de votre association est ce
qu'on peut être destinataire des statuts
de l'association
j'ai lu avec attention un article dans
marianne où vous dites qu'il ya une
charte qui fixe un cadre clair et
républicains à vos travaux est ce que
l'on peut être destinataire de cette
charte où vous pouvez nous en parler
et puis vous dites que la gouvernance de
votre association ou j'imagine des deux
associations permet de mettre à l'écart
ce qui dévierait de la ligne
de quelle ligne et de quelles pratiques
parlez vous voilà moi je souhaitais
avoir aujourd'hui ses premières réponses
à ces questions et ensuite je passerai
la parole à madame la rapporteure alors
question de l'islam de france l'islam de
france l'islam en france islam français
moi j'écris un livre qui s'appelle
l'islam est une religion française chez
gallimard
pourquoi islam de france il ya un islam
du maroc est un islam d'algérie il ya un
islam de tunisie il ya un islam de libye
un islam des égyptiens disent là-bas
c'est qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est une organisation nationale
pourquoi c'est important de parler
d'islam de france parce que ça veut dire
qu'on a besoin d'une organisation
nationale
il y en a pas besoin d'une organisation
finance est géré par des pays étrangers
notamment le maroc l'algérie la turquie
qui financent assez largement des
mosquées qui on voit des imams en accord
avec le ministère l'intérieur et qui
s'ingèrent dans des affaires qui devrait
des affaires franco-françaises
voilà pourquoi on parle 10
am de france ensuite la mif lamissia
deux associations et 19 cents à 1905 une
1901 qui a vocation culturelle une 1905
à vocation cultuelle et qui a notamment
vocation à recueillir des dons et dont
le premier objectif est de contribuer à
l'organisation de la formation des imams
la 1905 ne va pas ne doit pas former
elle même des imams mais organiser la
concertation avec des parties prenantes
musulmane pour que l'argent recueilli
permettent de mettre en place une
formation définies dans un cadre
républicain c'est-à-dire un cadre
républicain c'est tout simple vont poser
la question ça veut dire qu'on respecte
les lois de la république
il ya trente membres au conseil
d'administration des deux associations
les 30 même membre les bureaux sont
différents en fonction des spécialités
des uns et des autres nous avons publié
dans le monde
un texte au moment de la création de la
mif en novembre 2018 je pourrais je
pourrais vous l'envoyez chacun à signer
une charte éthique notamment qui
concerne les conflits d'intérêts parce
qu'un des problèmes aujourd'hui
l'organisation de l'islam en france
c'est les conflits d'intérêt notamment
les conflits d'intérêts économiques et
tous les membres ont été identifiés
sélectionnez d'une certaine manière ils
se sont auto institué personnes à nommer
tel ou tel canton créé une association
en france il ya un groupement de
personnes qui décident de créer une
association c'est ce qu'on a fait mais
il y avait un travail très important
d'identification des uns des autres
le connaissance de leur parcours et de
connaissances et c'est quand même
l'intérêt de leurs écrits de l'ordi et
de leurs écrits aujourd'hui certains ou
un parcours on va en parler moi je ne
préjuge pas du parcours des uns des
autres et je crois qu'on a le droit de
changer
voilà voilà comment ça s'est fait sur
quelles bases dans un état d'esprit qui
en est l esprit constructif et et avec
dans certains cas la satisfaction de
faire venir à nous des gens qui à
quelques années peut-être ne serais pas
venu si donc je considère que la réponse
l'amif aujourd'hui trente adhérents 30
membres qui parle donc au nom des
musulmans
c'est bien ce que l'on dit pardon la
miss n'a pas de vocation de
représentativité aucune n'a pas cette
ambition là n'a pas cette prétention
lors l'organisation qui doit représenter
les musulmans discuter sur le fait
qu'elle réussit ou pas c'est le cfcm et
les fédérations qui structure le cfcm
l'ambition de l'amif c'est d'être un
régulateur qui collecte des fonds parce
qu'elle a rendu un service
elle est rémunérée par une redevance et
elle réinvestit ce service là non pas
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
privatisant les bénéfices mais en les
socialisons ayant les socialisant pour
former d'un côté les imams on en a parlé
et pour travailler à la lutte contre
toutes les formes de haine li a dit cela
parce que je remercie madame le
rapportage oui alors plusieurs questions
du coup avec vos derniers propos
monsieur gare oui c'est un peu une un
business que vous allez mettre en place
si j'ai bien compris
mais peut-être que je mes propos sont un
peu excessive alors moi vous dit si je
peux vous hanter le post mais qu'est ce
que vous vous y répondre et moi je
voulais rester de la discussion
notez effectivement toutes les questions
vous répondrai en bloc après sheitan
question à vous poser bien évidemment ce
que j'ai regardé un peu précisément ce
qu est l ami est ce que souhaitait fallu
me sarr d'abord je voudrais savoir de
manière très claire si la création de
l'amif correspond où elle répond elle à
une demande du président de la
république de l'elysée des pouvoirs
publics
est ce que cette association voilà c'est
une attendu présents dans le public de
l'elysée ça c'est très important que
vous nous le préciser et puis avant
d'aller plus loin dans mes questions je
souhaite poser à saintes un nombre
d'entre vous je voudrais savoir si
autour de la table que aujourd'hui 6
face à nous nous avons des gens qui ont
été membres de la confrérie des frères
musulmans
c'est très important pour moi de savoir
puisque les frères musulmans sont pas ce
qu'on appelle les plus républicains de
ce pays et c'est une véritable
inquiétude pour un certain nombre de
lieux
ce pour un certain nombre de services de
renseignement dont deux ces deux
premières questions j'aimerais bien que
vous ai répondu et après j'en ai
d'autres
alors là me fait pas un business là me
fait une association qui vise à gérer et
réguler de façon transparente des
activités économiques avec cela me fait
n'est constitué que par des bénévoles et
la miss ne va enrichir personnes entre
nous c'est plutôt l'inversé vu le temps
passé à les travailler donc l'ami ce
n'est absolument pas un business l'amif
état régulateur sans vocation profitable
ensuite posez la question de est-ce que
c'est une demande du président de la
république je vous invite à lire ce
rapport donc qu'il a de 2016 président
de la république était pas président de
la république
tout est déjà décrit comme
recommandation par l'augmentation de
politiques publiques mais
recommandations à destination des
musulmans
ensuite je ne suis pas moi je n'ai
jamais été membre des frères musulmans
et entre nous poser la question et
grotesque après vous pouvez établir des
fiches sur les uns et sur les autres
j'ai vu ce qu'il y avait circulé
je sais par qui ça a été fait qu'on voit
là je pense que la parole est libre dans
ce pays tant qu'on ne distingue pas les
gens je pense que plusieurs fois il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui ont été
diffamés à eux de répondre moi m
peut-être tu répondes parce que je pense
qu'il ya des allégations le concernant
intéressante merci pour la question je
pense que c'est surtout la dernière qui
me concerne et comme il nous a été
demandé de parler sous serment
je suis très heureux vous remercie
madame la sénatrice pour votre question
et sa clarté
moi je suis venu en france en 99 je suis
né aux comores est un peu comme obélix
je suis tombé dans le
les sciences islamiques parce que j'ai
pas été ailleurs que chez moi j'ai été
formé par mon père et mes oncles
jusqu'en 99 ou chaud venu en france pour
faire mes études à l'université paris 7
où je fais des études de lettres
modernes 200 go stick dans la première
année jusqu'au doctorat
je n'ai jamais été frères musulmans de
ma vie si je dois avoir une confrérie à
linthal appartenir ce serait la
confrérie soufie bas alawiya de mon père
et de ses maîtres et de la confrérie de
charlie adam ma grand mère paternelle a
donné le terrain pour qu'elle soit
construite et c'est dedans que j'ai été
formé
il se trouve que en 2008
si ma mémoire est bonne il y à un
monsieur qui s'appelle sophie jazzy qui
aujourd'hui est actuellement en prison
en egypte qui est membre de les frères
musulmans qui venaient faire des
conférences en france librement je n'ai
jamais été dans un pays arabe où faire
des études ou vraiment que ce soit très
clair lorsque nous parlons sous serment
ce monsieur venait en france faire des
conférences et gelé servi de traducteur
je lui ai servi de traducteur et à ce
moment-là précis il y avait un livre de
tradition prophétique sur les traditions
prophétiques qui s'appelle mon club des
matinaux sera là je le dis en a rappelé
que tout le monde entende c'est un livre
ii des traditions du prophète
j'ai lu une partie 2 ou 3 pages avec ce
monsieur qui est des frères musulmans
je trouve grotesque à partir de là donc
tout ça c'est écrit de manière à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de doutes et ses mains
un élève qui avait posé la question il
ya maintenant cinq six sept huit ans je
crois et je leur ai répondu de manière à
ce que tout soit clair et que je n'ai
rien qu'on vienne pas dire que derrière
moi mais tu as aussi et cela est
malheureusement malgré cette
transparence
on continue à me dire que ben finalement
tué dans telle ou telle association en
2015 aux est aussi en réaction aux
attentats de 2015 un certain nombre de
théologiens se sont réunis sur mon
initiative et l'initiative d'un autre
ami qui s'appelle mohammad nadjar de
réunir des théologiens et je vous jeu
comment par l'eau sous serment je peux
vous dire que nous ne regardons pas la
couleur de la personne il s'agissait de
compétences théologie
on a créé une association qui s'appelle
cmf conseil théologie musulmans de
france même pas des musulmans de france
ce qu'on n'a pas du tout vocation à
représenter personnes on s'est dit on
créé cette association avec pour but
d'aider le musulman français qui le de
confession le français de confession
musulmane qui veut bien le faire et bien
l'aider à vivre à la fois son islamité
et sa francité
il se trouve que beaucoup parmi les
membres de cette association et est e2
apparemment des ex de l'usf et on a dit
que depuis l'an nguyen tat ismo tandis
et l'organisation de l'oeil f mais je
peux vous garantir de là puisque nous
parlons sous serment que cette noix en
tant que membre de ce conseil
je n'ai jamais eu affaire à lui f comme
organisation contrôla le cmf parce que
pour moi je n'ai aucun lien avec du
relief que ce soit très clair et net
très bien c'est très clair monsieur j'ai
jamais été moindres je t'en connais très
très longtemps
merci alors d'autres questions j'ai donc
vous parlait toujours de francité
d'islamité bassam cependant juste pour
non seulement nous n'avons pas été bons
mais notre objectif est de combattre
l'islamisme
je crois que les choses doivent être
claires et nettes dont on essaie
d'introduire le doute il n'y a
absolument aucun doute notre objectif et
je peux je tiens à votre disposition les
propos d'islamo identitaire les propos
du ccf les propos de marwan mohammed
regardez ce qu'ils disent de l'amif le
fait d'être attaqués à droite et à
gauche de tous côtés ça vous dit aussi
où vous êtes et je pense que ça ni plus
que les les accusations de tel ou tel
que par ailleurs on connaît assez bien
et dont on connaît l'histoire parfait
merci de cette précision il n'y a pas de
questions grotesque il ya des questions
que nous devons poser
s'ils doivent clarifier une situation
merci alors gelé revenir sur les mots
francité islamité qui m'interpelle nous
sommes français points et le reste nous
sommes des croyants et des non croyants
donc il me semble que quand nous vivons
sur le territoire nous sommes
la majoritairement français il y à des
étrangers et le reste c'est un
engagement personnel religieux donc
francité islamité ça m'interpelle un peu
je pense pas que ce soit comme ça qu'on
fasse avancer le sujet vous disiez tout
à l'heure monsieur bajra fine que vous
luttiez contre l'islam radical puis 2015
mais je pense que l'islam politique et
l'islam radical il est temps on a
constaté qu'il existe dans notre pays
bien avant 2015 2015 effectivement ça a
été les attendent à charlie mais il
fallait être un peu dans le déni
pour ne pas ça pour ne pas accepter
l'idée que ça remonte bien avant 2015
cet islam politique qui aujourd'hui et
c'est pas moi qui le dit uniquement
puisque le président a vu quant à parler
provoque une certaine partition existe
depuis les années 2000
c'est exactement à ce moment là que les
autres que les choses ont commencé à
arriver à évoluer d'un pays est alors en
2000 justement c'est une question je
voulais vous poser monsieur barja fille
lui au relief avait exigé avait exigé le
retrait d'une clause dans le texte qui
s'appelait principes et fondements
juridiques régissant les rapports entre
les pouvoirs publics et le culte
musulman en france qui reconnaissait le
droit de changer de religion a exigé
qu'on retire cette partie là dont moi je
voulais savoir si la peau stasi quelque
chose qui va être autorisée ou qui est
autorisé dans l'islam et je voulais
savoir que vous en tant que vice
président de l'amif de cette partie
cultuelle est ce que vous pensez
est-ce que vous admettez qu'un musulman
a le droit de quitter l'islam pour une
autre religion ou est ce qu'il ne peut
plus en avoir du tout sans être menacé
sans être attaqué ça c'est une première
question je voulais vous poser
et puis j'en ai une deuxième parce que
vous avez des références théologiques de
certains prêts d'acteurs prédicateur
islamiste pardon non peut-être
prédateurs danse intérieur dont certains
ont soutenu le djihad armé et des
pratiques qui pour moi sont contraire
totalement valeurs humanistes notre pays
donc je voulais savoir en tant que vice
président de l'amif toujours dédié je
crois à la formation des imams
si j'ai bien compris voilà je voudrais
savoir ce que vous pensez de youssef al
qardaoui et est-ce qu'il est toujours
une référence pour vous puisque vous
avez dit dans une vidéo que qaradawi
c'est un très grand savant quelqu'un qui
a fait énormément de bien à notre
communauté
donc on peut quand même s'interroger sur
voilà pour vous admirez ce type de
personnes ça peut nous nous interroger
républicain que nous sommes parce que
nous sommes tous des républicains sur ce
que veut faire la mif pour lutter contre
ses excès de la religion je réponds à la
première question
merci encore pour la clarté de vos de
vos questions qui me permettent de
développer un certain nombre de choses
que ce soit bien clair avant 2015
je vous ai parlé de 2015 comme point de
départ n'ont pas de mon combat au
quotidien parce que je suis imam dans
plusieurs mosquées depuis très longtemps
et ce combat je l'aimais et je continue
encore de le faire donc sur le terrain
mais c'est seulement parce que en 2015
il s'est passé des événements tragiques
qui ont secoué le pays et c'est aussi
parce qu'en 2015 j'ai commis un livre
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure la
question que vous posez qui est de
savoir si je je supporte qu'un musulman
puisse quitter sa religion
non seulement je suis pour qu'il puisse
le faire
je les ai écrit dans mon livre en 2015
et dans celui aussi de 2018
je pense que la peine d' apostasie
condamnant la personne à la mort pour
avoir changé de religion de mon point de
vue est anti islamique
mais je ne vais pas le dire la
développer ici parce que c'est pas le
lieu
mais c'est juste vous répondre que non
seulement j'y suis favorable mais je
pense que la peine qui a été prononcée
de mon point de vue n'a pas de source
théologique sur laquelle pouvoir sexuées
donc je vous le dis en toute en été
parce que j'ai cette conviction
chevillée au corps
deuxième question que vous
posée au sujet de l ue se fait alors
draghi je pense l'avoir dit vous avez vu
une vidéo mais je les dis dans d'autres
vidéos que d'abord je n'ai jamais vu
donc je n'ai jamais rencontré donc je ne
sais pas que ce soit très clair encore
et toi puisque nous parlons sous serment
ensuite je vais préciser dans pas mal
d'endroits en quoi ce monsieur a été une
référence
je vous le dis ici jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu alors je vous parle beaucoup parmi
ceux qui se réfèrent à la juriste
jurisprudence musulmane traditionnelle
estime que que ce soit très clair et
bref estime qu'une femme quand elle est
tué 1 à tort par quelqu'un par un
accident de watts dans un accident de
voiture par exemple
elle vaut la moitié en termes de
dédommagement de l'homme et ce monsieur
a été le premier et le seul à ma
connaissance à l'avoir dit donc je suis
clairement dans mes bottes de dire que
sur cette question là ce monsieur a été
une référence mais de grâce sur très
clair là-dessus vraiment mais que ce
soit avec les choses que ce soit clair
et net
là dessus pour moi c'était une
révolution parce que je n'ai jamais eu
un théologien musulman avant lui qui a
tenu ce discours qui est celui que je
défends bah en fait ce que j'ai voulu
dire c'est que ce monsieur il se fera
dans un oui je me répète a dit que quand
une femme est tuée est injustement elle
vaut en terme de dédommagement que ce
que vaut un homme point à la ligne
et la décharge je m'excuse si j'ai été
je dis les choses autrement et à partir
de là je me dis que lui sur ce point là
qui n'est pas mon maître je répète mon
maître c'est mon père aimait être moi je
le jem et j'en rencontre elle se voit
lorsqu'on parle de sous ses marques
serment là dessus il m'a été une
référence et je le pense que il est le
seul à ma connaissance je le dis encore
une fois à ma connaissance avoir tenu ce
discours là sur cette question sur les
autres points de vue qu'il qu'il a
développés je suis en totale opposition
avec l'idée de faire le
de tuer des gens sous forme de jean
adoue je ne sais quoi je n'ai jamais
soutenu un propos pareils et je vous
demanderais encore une fois de relire ce
que j'ai écrit puisque j'ai écris
aujourd'hui deux ou trois livres sur ces
questions là je suis très clair et je
répète pour moi l'apostasié est une
peine antimusulman et cette question qui
l'a dit pour moi et elle a été
révolutionnaire dans le droit musulman
j'espère avoir répondu à vos questions
ce que je peux compléter vos amis via un
conseil d'administration
si jamais nous avions le moindre doute
sur une personne sept personnes seraient
exclues de la mif et et le doute il est
très simple les règles sont très simples
nous sommes la république il ya des lois
on respecte les lois de la république et
les lois de la république sont au dessus
des lois religieuses qui sont des lois
personnel mathieu les choses sont très
claires
parfait ou et bien répondu que je
transmets trier les documents tout à
fait donc pas de souci les jeunes nombre
de tâches je pense que si vous me
permettez juste rajouter une chose c'est
que pour nous en tout cas pour moi il
n'y a pas de théocratie dire que pour
moi elle voit religieuse c'est une
chèque tout cas dans le temps et qu'il
convient aux hommes de s'organiser comme
bon leur semble c'est en snack je trouve
que l'islam politique est une
supercherie et c'est pas devant vous que
je le dis seulement je les ai déjà dit
avant les pistes
jacques riou juste dire une phrase vous
savez les français ils sont pas
représentés par les religieux les
français sont représentées par des élus
qui représentent le peuple français ce
sont les élus sont pas des religieux
je veux dire une place que c'est quand
on dit nous représentons les musulmans
ça veut dire quoi les trois quarts ils
sont français qui représentait musulmans
qui sont français
ce sont les élus donc voilà donc majeur
c'est très important
bah c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure donc voilà non là mais important
parce que le peuple français qu'ils
soient athées catholiques musulmans
bouddhistes ou rien du tout ou juifs ils
représentaient par des élus en france on
est représentée par des élus
alors il ya une question qui j'en ai
deux autres après oui laisser reposer
ghazi rejet d'horaires et après je
reprendrai bien ce que j'ai demandé est
ce que chacun vous puissiez me donner
les horaires donc je vais pouvoir faire
selon vos contraintes
mes chers collègues et nous les
comprenons donc rachel mazuir si vous
voulez bien peser vraiment les gens
suivent vous prie de m'excuser mais oui
je vais à marcoussis ce vous savez c'est
là où se passe le rugby aujourd'hui et
bompard éclatez vous invite à pardonner
au plus tard donc vous avez évoqué les
iraniens bon je pensais un peu
particulier par rapport à l'islam
majoritairement sunnite en france et ils
sont plutôt si j'ai bien sûr le tronc
organisé et hiérarchiquement c'est
beaucoup dire mais en fait ils sont
organisés
alors vous avez dit que c'était un
combat théologique et vous avez dit la
bataille ne se gagnera pas sans les
musulmans alors la question et avec quel
musulman parce que aujourd'hui et une
inorganisation manifeste et les ordres
interlocuteurs sont difficiles à trouver
pour avoir vraiment une réponse qui
puisse être celle de l'ensemble des
musulmans de france et la première
question
et puis ensuite vais parler de former
des religieux et vous avez dit qu'il
fallait les payer
alors bon on est dans un état l'oeil je
vous apprends rien et donc c'est pas
l'état qui les paiera donc c'est une
question qui allait payer
et puis ensuite troisième question en
troisième remarque vous avez dit et
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas de statistiques
officielles soit interdite
on sait par contre que certains
organismes ont fait des sondages et
notamment paraît-il satie syrien plutôt
du côté de
des états unis et que entre autres ces
statistiques disent par exemple qu'en
france c'est au prix de l'emploi je veux
dire enfin au moins de lecture que j'ai
eus qui peuvent être contestées en 2050
les agnostiques et les athées sera
majoritaire alors la tenais ma question
est la suivante est ce qu'il existe dans
les communautés long turc maghrébine
disons vous n'y voyez pas quelques trucs
cachés
je veux dire dans les communautés qui se
revendique donc de tout c'est de tous
ces pays est ce qu'il existe des
associations qui regroupent les
agnostiques ou des athées c'est une
assez ma troisième question sous un prix
merci monsieur le sénateur je jouerai
pour rapidement vous dites qu'il faut
une organisation je vous réponds je suis
bien d'accord avec vous c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire sans organisation on ne
pourra pas mener cette bataille
théologique idéologique et culturelle
sans organisation et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui où avec une désorganisation
totale
en fait ceux qui prennent ce qu'ils
mènent là la partie ce sont les plus
militants donc on a besoin
d'organisation
on a besoin de moyens on a besoin de
transparence est une façon d'avoir des
moyens c'est de rendre des services
transparents professionnelle et efficace
cette organisation l'amif n'a pas
vocation à travailler tout seul et on
espère que le cfcm
il ya un nouveau président il ya un
nouveau recteur de la mosquée de paris
qui ont l'air d'avoir des dispositions
qui sont favorables
le cfcm a vocation à représenter le
culte les mosquées la miss a vocation à
être une caisse de financement et puis
il faut un travail théologique à côté
notre modèle quand on regarde ce qui
existe vous disiez madame que
les croyants n'ont pas vocation à être
présente et ils n'ont pas vocation à
être présentés ils ont vocation à être
organisé l'église de france est une
organisation des croyants le consistoire
central du judaïsme c'est une
organisation des croyants la fédération
protestante c'est une organisation des
croyants plus musulmans sont des
français comme les autres ils peuvent
être organisées comme les autres en tant
que croyants on a besoin de ces trois
pôles un pôle d'organisation du culte
on a besoin d'un pôle de financement et
on a besoin d'un d'un pôle théologique
pour ne pas laisser la théologie au aux
extrémistes vous parliez pardon c'était
votre troisième question oui le
financement le financement c'est tout
l'enjeu le financement aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est l'objectif premier de
l'amif c'est de le rendre transparent et
non pas de le prélever sous
l'intermédiaire d'un navire d'une taxe
notamment pas du tout une taxe public
mais par à une redevance par un service
rendu aux fidèles sur des moments de
leur vie où ils sont amenés à avoir à
consommer afin à payer quelque chose
pour le pèlerinage par exemple ou tout
simplement quand il donne quand ils
donnent de l'argent
le troisième sujet c'est lise la
question était qui financerait les imams
je pense que à terme ce serait bien de
pouvoir financer les images si ce n'est
complètement au moins en partie et par
exemple sur leurs droits sociaux vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui
ah ben si la miss a suffisamment de
moyens je pense qu'elle a vocation à
d'abord à instituer une diplomation
comme celle claire du consistoire
central est allé jusqu'à soit des
revenus va donner des revenus globaux
soit donné des compléments de revenus
pourquoi c'est important parce que vous
avez un lien entre la diplomation et et
le revenu donc ça sert à quelque chose
de fort mais si ça ensuite un impact sur
les revenus des uns et des autres le
troisième sujet c'est vous parlez des ex
musulmans alors y'a des voix est ce
qu'il ya des organisations je ne sais
pas dans l' enquête qu'on avait fait
avec l'institut montaigne on avait vu
qu'il y avait environ 15% de alors pas
des français parce qu'il y avait des
étrangers mais des gens qui avaient des
parents musulmans qui ne se disait plus
musulman donc il ya une part assez
importante de deux personnes de culture
musulmane qui ne se disent plus
aujourd'hui musulmans merci sur la
question de la relativité et puis de
l'élection effectivement il ya un
syllogisme puis en fait le syllogisme
c'est l'islam et au style de la laïcité
or la laïcité est essentielle à la
démocratie donc l'islam est hostile à
alam démocratie c'est un syllogisme
qu'il faut pouvoir dénoncer matin
effectivement dans les espèces de grands
groupes socio anthropologique des
musulmans en france
eh bien il ya des musulmans qui sont en
voie de sécularisation ou envoi de
retrait ou de séparation de la de l'âme
de la religion il ya des musulmans qui
sont tentés c'était le d'un des grands
bienfaits de la utilité de cette enquête
de l'institut montaigne et des musulmans
qui sont tentés par une logique
sécessionnistes et qui vont à ânonner on
est chez nous qui est similaire au on
est chez nous d'autres extrême et puis
il ya les musulmans de là
de la majorité silencieuse des slams des
familles tranquille alors ils sont
silencieux mais sans majorité
ils sont majorité mais ils sont
silencieux c'est ce qu'on essaie aussi
de fédérer
jacqueline eustache brinio quatre
questions complémentaires 3 3 questions
pour vous monsieur el karoui alors une
première question en 2018 sur france
culture
vous avez dit que le modèle français est
un modèle d'assimilation et d'oppression
de la majorité sur la minorité
vous évoquez une immense xénophobie du
modèle français et un niveau de
discrimination extrêmement élevé moi
j'ai eu en banlieue franchement je suis
pas sûr que ce soit aussi violent que ça
donc la mif effectivement se donne comme
objectif de lutter contre le racisme en
particulier anti musulmans qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas franchement prix
prouver parce que des actes antisémites
on en voit tous les jours me des actes
contre la communauté musulmane et c'est
tant mieux on en va pas quand même pas
tous les jours alors vous souhaitez
gérer représenté 7
ce culte musulman en france par
présentent des taux oui enfin le gérer
ça c'est ambigu quand vous dites pas
représentés cercle si vous dites que
gérer je redis ce que j'ai dit au début
c'est du business
et si vous dites pas représentée à
semblant se demande à quoi ça sert et je
voudrais juste vous poser une question
est ce que le modèle républicain
français vous semble t'il inconciliable
avec les droits des citoyens français de
la religion musulmane mais ce qu'avec
vos propos vous quand même un peu
violent sur ce qui se passe
éventuellement ce pour la communauté
musulmane j'aimerais voir section une
autre question à lorient ça vous
concerne pas complètement mais comme
vous avez travaillé ensemble monsieur
tariq oubrou il président n'a misé sur
la partie cultuelle on est d'accord
voilà et il a été membre fondateur du
conseil théologique musulmans de france
je crois avec vous monsieur jeu il me
semble voilà et dans ce conseil
théologique des musulmans de france
on y voit quand même beaucoup de gens
qui viennent de lyon f qui est à ma
connaissance la branche française des
frères musulmans donc
je me pose question pourquoi dents au
sein de la mif il y a des gens qui sont
si proches de l'unef
je sais que monsieur tariq oubrou a
quitté lioret fils l'a dit s'exprimer
depuis 2018 donc au moment où la mif a
été créé donc moi la question que je me
pose c'est que est ce qu'il rejette
complètement l'idéologie islamique et
vous avez désigné dans la fabrique de
l'islamisme puisque je lé là vous
désigner les frères musulmans comme
l'une des deux grandes mouvances de
l'islamisme vous monsieur pensez vous
pourtant vous insistez sur la lutte
contre le salafisme
alors je veux une pose la question
pensez vous que les frères musulmans
sont moins dangereux que les salafistes
et ma dernière question concerne le
voile qui est un marqueur pour moi
politique le voile moi je mène depuis
longtemps un combat contre le voile pour
plein de raisons parce que je pense que
c'est aussi une liberté c'est voilà on
voit aujourd'hui des femmes dans des
quartiers entiers de la région
parisienne qui vivent avec des tenues
qui sont loin d'être la liberté et
d'ailleurs je disais je vais faire une
comparaison peut être très violente
mais l'ayatollah khomeini quand il
apprit vous voir son premier geste
politique ça a été de mettre les femmes
sous l'abaya et je me dis que dans les
quartiers dans certains quartiers
populaires de france nous voilons nous
avons la même là même le même objectif
politique
alors je vous pose la question du voile
parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
m'interpelle dans vos propos dans votre
livre vous avez écrit que comme français
je me battrai pour que les musulmans
puissent exercer leur culte
bon ça y'a pas de soucis y compris pour
que les femmes aient le droit de porter
le voile dans l'espace public
puis certaines d'entre elles puisse
quasi tiennent mais comme musulman je me
bats pour que mes coreligionnaires
laisse de côté les interprétations
fausse donc inutilement rigoriste donc
ce qui m'interpelle c'est ce ces deux
axes du en même temps quand je suis
français j'ai une position qui est celle
là et comme musulman j'ai cette position
qui est celle là donc cette double
position par exemple sur le voile
m'interpelle beaucoup donc je voudrais
avoir votre analyse finale sur le port
du voile est en partie due
et sur cette petite fille et ses jeunes
filles qui sont voilées de plus en plus
tôt dans nos quartiers en tout cas en
banlieue parisienne
la hausse en mai plus content puisque
vous aussi votre temps à côté sur un
point d'orgue parce que je trouve que
l'organisation de cette commission
denquête n'est pas du tout acceptable
sous cette forme
je ne conçois pas je n'ai jamais vu une
commission denquête ou la commission
denquête est en fête organisée à faire
entre un dialogue entre le rapporteur à
la personne auditionnée il ya deux ans
des intermèdes et des intermèdes
publicitaires ou les autres membres de
la commission denquête peuvent poser des
questions pas du tout j'ai pris la
question de monsieur la chaîne mère me
disais moi je peux quand même
enfin je pense que lorsque vous me
donnez la parole je peux au moins faire
un point d'ordre avant de commencer mais
qu'il est efficace que si vous voulez en
général
le rapporteur effectivement à priorité
pour poser des questions au début et
après les autres membres de l'opposition
d'un côté c'est fait c'est monsieur
xavier si vous aviez monsieur mazuir
qu'il y avait un vrai problème de
contrat mais c'est bien d'avoir brisé la
cnam la présidence ce débat c'est la
première fois je ce n'est pas la
prostate
lorsque vous n'avez pas fait beaucoup
d'auditions donc je pense que vous
n'avez pas assister à toutes les
auditions des sources sûres que je dois
leur en faire beaucoup plus et monsieur
le camp propose de poser votre question
des désaxés temps en tant que
vice-président de la commission denquête
je répète que je considère qu'à un
moment effectivement il ya bien entendu
priorité aux rapporteurs pour poser des
questions mais qu' après effectivement
les membres de la commission enquête
puis peuvent doivent pouvoir poser des
questions ont été faits et pas voilà en
un service à monsieur d'entre vous
faites un point d'ordre qui en fait je
ne me rendrais plus services comme
monsieur le comte grâce à vous merci
alors sur le lorsque je je je je vous
entends j'ai quelques quelques
interrogations parce que de cette
commission enquête deux précédentes
je veux bien entendu et compris que
finalement le le manque de connaissance
même de personnes de chi chi chi chi chi
chi qui pratiquent la religion musulmane
de 2,2 de la région de musulmane peut
engendrer des des faiblesses qui peuvent
engendrer des manipulations menant à
l'extrémisme
mais cette observation peut-elle être
transformée comme vous le faites en
combat idéologique ou est ce que c'est
ça doit être simplement une ouverture
sur la connaissance
parce que là vraiment vous présenter sa
commune un combat idéologique et
théologique
alors que finalement il n'y a pas qu'en
france où la conception de la pratique
de la religion musulmane a évolué au
cours des trente dernières années
et si on voit partout y a pas qu'en
france
quels sont les deux vecteurs la
situation sociale et les moyens et les
moyens de certains pays en particulier
du golfe s'est pas fondamentalement des
dialogues entre grenade s'est pas
fondamentalement dédia ou théologiques
ces deux de deux éléments marquants qui
ont fondamentalement fait voler la
situation en france comme dans beaucoup
de pays et moi ce qui me gêne c'est est
ce que vraiment vous vous considérez
dans un combat idéologique ou dans une
dans une et théologiques ou dans
finalement le devoir de d'approfondir la
connaissance
parce que si vous aller plus loin parce
que ce qui choque aussi c'est quand vous
vous évoquez finalement la nécessité
presque de faire une norme nationale
pour l'islam
enfin l'islam et divers est ce qu'on
peut de cette diversité tirer une norme
vouloir tirer une norme
est-ce que c'est pas justement là qu'est
le danger est est-ce que c'est pas en
essayant de vouloir faire une norme
qu'il ya des combats qui peuvent mener à
l'extrémisme et et ce qui est encore
plus dangereux c'est quand vous inciter
finalement les pouvoirs publics à
rentrer dans la fabrication de cette
norme où le conseil le csm a aussi était
à mon sens une dérive parce que
finalement les pouvoirs publics sont
rentrés dans cette volonté de
de normes est quelque chose que les
pouvoirs publics n'ont pas aux normes et
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur de
ce rappel à la sérénité puis à
l'enseignement finalement moi j'ai envie
de vous répondre avec deux citations
brève
la première l et d'averroès averroès il
disait l'ignorance mène à la peur la
peur mène à la haine et la haine conduit
à la lame à la violence c'est vrai qu'il
ya une primauté il ya un primat de
l'amélioration delà de la connaissance
et ans à vous avez absolument raison
c'est en ça que cette dimension que l'on
discutait de prêts ne pas être
uniquement sur le registre du cultuel
mais également du culturel
raison pour laquelle avait cité la
fondation en islam de france qui est
actuellement faible sur un plan
quantitatif mais qui est essentiel soit
plan qualitatif la deuxième citation
c'est saint paul la lettre tue c'est
l'esprit qui donne la vie effectivement
finalement il faut aller c'est d'aller
au delà de l'orthodoxie est plutôt de
l'orthodoxie la question le mystique
soufie sa crise on sait pas de
s'astreindre à faire ses cinq prières
par jour
la question c'est de faire de sa vie une
prière vous n'êtes que c'est trop
irénique mais la partie essentielle et
que on a un déficit de compréhension de
l'islam y compris de la part de nos
propres coreligionnaires il ya une
incompréhension ou une méconnaissance de
la part de nos concitoyens quelle que
soit leur religion et quelles que soient
leurs croyances
effectivement le bon premier premier pas
est celui de la connaissance la
connaissance et de la première lutte
contre la peur de l'autre
je voudrais rajouter une petite chose
par rapport à ce qui a été
ce qui vient d'être dit à savoir que
personnellement ce que je
je me fixe comme combat c'est d'aider
l'autre à se passer de moi c'est à dire
que le savoir c'est vraiment le combat
essentiel qui doit être mené il se
trouve malheureusement que aujourd'hui
il y à une prégnance une
sur-représentation une domination de
cette idéologie littéraliste à laquelle
vous faisait allusion qui se mélangent
lorsqu'elle n'est pas années de nulle
part il vient en effet d'un certain
nombre de moyens qui ont été investis
par certains états du golfe je pense que
tout le monde dans cette commission être
conscient de cette situation et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on en est venu à une
situation où c'est plutôt cette manière
de vivre l'islam qui a pignon sur rue et
les autres sont un peu relégués au
second plan comme has been et je pense
que là pour le coup c'est une question
de combat mon combat c'est de faire en
sorte que toutes les voies puissent être
entendus et naturellement celles qui
sont qui portent atteinte qu'ils
appellent à la haine qui portent
atteinte à la vie humaine celle là parce
que contrevenant à la loi doivent être
interdites en revanche encore une fois
je pense pas que le rôle de la mif en
tout cas c'est pas comme ça que nous
autres nous le concevons soin de dire
qui est le bon et qui est le mauvais
musulman se doit pas être sale but sinon
ce sera trompé de combat
le but doit au contraire de faire en
sorte que et bien toutes personnes
vivent en totale liberté de croire ou de
ne pas croire pour revenir à cette
question si importante aujourd'hui et
surtout d'éviter encore une fois que ce
soit lors toprak s'il orthopraxie à
laquelle faisait allusion le professeur
belloucif à l'instant qu'il emporte et
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui même des gens
qui n'ont pas forcément une vision
salafistes de la chose qui ne pratiquent
pas le salafisme mais quand on pense
islam c'est certain mais on pense
salafisme et c'est pas du tout ça ce que
nous devrions avoir comme objectif
monsieur aller car oui je pense que vous
voulez compléter oui il ya beaucoup de
questions et je vous en remercie
je remercie chaman 2
mes livres notamment le premier qui
s'appelle l'avenir d'une exception qui
est sous titré pourquoi le monde a
encore besoin des français et je vous
invite à le site est complètement parce
que je parle du paradoxe du modèle
français
je pense qu'effectivement la france
pratique l'assimilation l'assimilation
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire on a une
idée collective inconsciente 1 qui
consiste à dire nous croyons dans les
valeurs de l'universalité la valeur
d'une universalité c'est quoi c'est nous
sommes tous des citoyens égaux c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
avec une question qui est qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec les étrangers les
étrangers ne sont pas comme nous puisque
ce sont des étrangers
ils peuvent être porteurs de valeurs et
d'organisations différentes et c'est le
cas des maghrébins d'ailleurs plus que
des italiens ou des espagnols en termes
de structures anthropologiques
je vous renvoie notamment aux travaux
d'emmanuel todd et qu'est ce qui se
passe j'essaye de comprendre le paradoxe
avec un double phénomène
pardon mais un niveau discrimination
extraordinairement élevé et je vous
renvoie aux travaux encore de l'institut
montaigne qui a fait un testing tous les
testings disent la même chose quand vous
êtes quand vous avez le même nom de
famille un prénom différent un prénom
qui a une consonance catholique une
consonance juive une consonance
musulmane le nom de famille ca date vous
avez le même le même parcours le même cv
5000 cv ont été envoyés quand vous êtes
un homme avec un prénom musulman et un
petit engagement religieux
vous avez été membre des scouts
musulmans vous avez cinq fois moins de
chances d'avoir un entretien que quand
vous êtes un homme ou une femme avec un
prénom catholique demandé regardez
autour de vous demander la question je
la discrimination
elle est très élevée elle est très très
très mesurée par tous donc on a on a
d'un côté il y à une enquête vous
parliez de la francité c'est pas moi qui
utilise le terme c'est un concept
qu'utilise l'ined l'institut national
d'études démographiques dans son enquête
et aux trajectoires et origines qui
s'interroge sur la trajectoire des
enfants d'immigrés ils ont interrogé un
certain nombre d'enfants d'immigrés qui
disent à 40% souffrir d'un déni de
francité on leur dit vous n'êtes pas des
français comme les autres
il ya cette réalité là d'une forme de
rejet
et puis il ya une autre réalité en même
temps qui est celle de du nombre
extraordinairement élevé de mariages
mixtes
quand on compare la france avec d'autres
pays occidentaux plus intéressant c'est
de comparer la france et les états unis
aux états unis à des noir et blanc et
des blancs qui vivent ensemble depuis
350 ans et 3 pour 100 mariages mixtes
entre une femme noire est un homme blanc
aux états france au bout de cinquante
ans de vie commune
en métropole on est à 25 % entre des
maghrébins notamment des maghrébines et
des français donc on a à la fois
extraordinaire ouverture sans
comparaison avec le reste du monde
occidental et de l'autre côté un moment
avant qui à un moment de fermeture
et qui est ce moment de re j'ai ressenti
à la fois mesuré est ressenti par ces
français d'origine étrangère
ça c'est le paradoxe français et c'est
l'assimilation l'assimilation dit que
tant vous n'êtes pas comme nous d'une
certaine manière on a un doute on vous
rejette vous rejette symboliquement mais
à partir du moment où il ya plus de
grandes différences et le voile est un
exemple de cette grande différence à
partir du moment où il ya plus cette
grande différence perçu vous êtes
considéré comme un français comme un
autre et la meilleure preuve c'est que
on se marie avec vous ce qui n'existe
pas dans le reste du monde occidental
donc le paradoxe français un moment si
vous laisser on rentre dans l'atmosphère
dans l'atmosphère nationale dans
l'atmosphère républicaine on se
dépouille de ce qu'on aime c'est un
grand moment de l'acculturation c'est
aussi un moment dangereux
pourquoi parce que c'est le moment où on
n'est plus de son pays d'origine et on
n'est pas encore français
c'est là où je vous les islamistes c'est
là où je vous les islamistes c'est pour
ça que c'est très important de nommer
c'est très important de dire vous êtes
des français comme les autres vous avez
vocation à être des français comme les
autres parce qu'il ya un moment
d'inquiétude ya un moment d'incertitude
et puis à la fin de ce trajet il ya
l'accès non seulement la nationalité non
seulement la citoyenneté mais l'accès à
l'identité et ça on le voit et c'est le
paradoxe que que que l'on mesure cette
majorité silencieuse qui est intégré et
qu'on ne voit plus et c'est la
difficulté d'une certaine manière dans
ce modèle français d'assimilation le
succès est silencieux complètement
silencieux l'échec lui est très criants
parce que l'échec dit mais enfin
ce que vous remettez en cause c'est
notre idéal universel puisque nous on
pense que tous les hommes sont égaux
si vous n'acceptez pas à notre identité
universel peut-être que vous remettez en
cause notre idée l'universel d'où cette
réaction
on parle du voile moelleux la loi
française autorise de voile mois comme
musulman ch je suis opposé au voile
c'est ça c'est ça ce que ça veut dire
j'essaye d'expliquer aux uns et aux
autres
pourquoi le voile peut être perçue par
certains pas par tous comme quelque
chose d'insupportable notamment j'étais
aux états unis récemment américains se
disent les français sont sont fous
xénophobes et racistes
comment comment il peut même y avoir un
débat sur le voile jeudi le voile
finalement ça peut être ça peut être
perçu précisément comme cette grande
différence la grande différence entre
les hommes et les femmes n'y a pas de
différend il n'y a pas de grandes
différences entre les hommes et les
femmes et les femmes en france dans le
modèle républicain
et donc c'est perçu par les français la
majorité des français que quelque chose
d'irréductible pourquoi le voile c'est
quoi ça peut être quoi un déni de
liberté
les gens n'imaginent pas qu'on puisse
porter le voile librement interrogés des
femmes voilées certaines d'entre elles
vous diront le contraire
mais allez y et libertés deuxième chose
un déni d'égalité
si les hommes étaient voilées c'est le
cas chez les sikhs 1 c'est pas absurde
si les hommes été volé ce qu'ils ont un
tueur bon il n'y aurait pas cette
question de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes
et puis aussi un déni de fraternité
parce que le voile c'est une séparation
c'est une séparation entre vous et la
société c'est une séparation entre vous
corps musulman ou identifié comme un
corps musulmans et le reste de la
société corps non musulmans donc le
voile et c'est pour ça qu'il ya un débat
en france sur le voile le voile peut
être perçue interprété comme une
question posée à l'idée d'universel moi
je pense que
les femmes ne doivent pas porter le
voile c'est parce que dit la loi pour
pouvoir répond alors tariq oubrou moi je
vous dire plusieurs choses
convoqué par ekobo deuxième chose lisez
les livres de tarik au bo troisièmement
interrogé alain juppé sur tariq au bout
il est imam de bordeaux alain juppé a
été longtemps maire de bordeaux
quatrièmement regarder la carte du
jihadisme en france regardez ce qui se
passe à bordeaux mais surtout surtout
lisez le écoutez le et puis c'est
toujours intéressant
regardez ce que disent les islamistes de
lui il a son trajet hélas son parcours
je crois qu'on a le droit de changer je
crois que j'ai un ancien premier
ministre qui était trotskiste je pense
que quand il était premier ministre il
était plus trotskiste certains disent
aghilès était la taqiyya la
dissimulation
après le salafisme on saura jamais mais
moi dans ces cas là vous savez je pense
qu'il vaut mieux regarder les faits non
mais je sonne ne peut échapper
mais regardons les faits en l'occurrence
avec tarik au bout regardons les faits
regardons les écrits regardons les 10
les salafistes
alors j'ai entendu dire effectivement je
sous-estimaient l'emprise des frères
musulmans et que je surestimaient celle
des salafistes
je regarde la dynamique la dynamique en
france elle est générationnel les frères
musulmans ils sont arrivés enfin ce
qu'on appelle les enfants des frères
musulmans parce qu'il n'ya pas une
organisation qui s'appelle les frères
musulmans il y en a une qui existe elle
est enneigée temps il y en a pas
ailleurs dans le monde
mais les frères musulmans ils sont
arrivés étudiants maghrébins en général
en sciences dans les années 80 en france
venant essentiellement du maroc et de
tunisie
ils ont créé une première organisation
qui a changé de nom plusieurs fois
qu'ils étaient lus rief aujourd'hui
musulmans de france
je sais pas si vous avez invité amar
lasfar je pense que ça vaut le coup
d'auditionner amar lasfar ainsi si je
puis me permettre
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya eu un
conflit mais depuis 20 ans entre les
fondateurs et la génération d'après les
fondateurs qui étaient des étrangers qui
parlait bien l'arabe
on dit aux jeunes membres des frères
musulmans
wouts façon vous n'aurez jamais
responsabilité dans l'organisation parce
que vous n'êtes pas d'assez bons musée
et vous ne connaissez pas suffisamment à
la fois la langue et le texte coranique
ça a donné un premier départ de
génération aujourd'hui la dynamique elle
est pas chez les frères musulmans les
frères musulmans ils se sont soulevés f
ils se sont institutionnalisés
ils ont fait du business moi j'ai
rencontré amar lasfar il me dit moi je
suis un businessman lui fait du tourisme
il fait du pèlerinage il fait que
l'aérien il a encore une activité
religieuse mais pour moi le sujet il a
migré de deux côtés vers les
identitaires je regarde où sont leurs
enfants leurs enfants symbolique vers
les identitaires incarner d'une certaine
manière par le ccf
ce discours qui met au coeur de
l'identité non seulement l'islam mais la
discrimination subie par les musulmans à
travers le concept ambigu d'islamophobie
ça c'est une chose et puis il ya une
deuxième branche autour du salafisme
autour du nez au salafisme qui est en
train de muter qui est pas celui des
années des années 90 ou du début des
années 2000 qui est un lien évident avec
le djihadisme et qui est surtout ceux
qui a disons le type d'organisation qui
aujourd'hui a le vent en poupe
c'est pour ça je pense que c'est
important de décrire le salafisme on l'a
fait notamment et je viens de vous en
reparler très en détail sur ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit à l'échelle mondiale les salafistes
les grands leaders les grands
prédicateurs ont dix fois plus de
followers que le plus connu des frères
musulmans le cheikh qardaoui ce soit à
l'échelle internationale où que ce soit
à l'échelle nationale donc aujourd'hui
dans la structuration de l'islamisme
notamment chez les jeunes je pense que
c'est chez les jeunes que ça nous
intéresse les courants porteurs
c'est les identitaires d'un côté les
salafistes ou néo salafistes de l'autre
très bien j'en remercie jean marc est un
problème d'horaire ont soit je suis très
gentille je continuais très gentil mais
on ne m'en fais pas la remarque au soir
je passe la question à la première qui a
demandé si les gauches à jean marie
jean-marie parce que tu as un impératif
aurait remercie pas un vrai problème
c'est un résident asie le rendez vous
téléphonique à 6h30 qui sera assez court
posta question je la pose à 20 mais ça
ne dérange pas ok merci présidente
oui donc messieurs moi je trouve en
effet votre audition très très
intéressante et c'est sûr que on est sur
des sujets sur lesquels tâtonne à peu
tous mais il faut reconnaître que
beaucoup ont tâtonné avant nous et va en
citer différentes organisations ne parce
que moi j'ai un peu de mémoire je suis
pas là pour affirmer des convictions
pour vous questionner mais c'est juste
pour dire dont je parle et je me
souviens un peu à l'époque toujours pas
dans le contexte de l'époque
l'espérance qu'ont suscité certaines
initiatives prises par l'état français
sur le culte l'uimm
j'ai connu l'époque chevènement un homme
d'état français pour lequel je conserve
le minime ans estime mais je me souviens
c'était intéressé à ces questions il
avait lancé des initiatives nicolas
sarkozy enfin il y en a eu d'autres
et chaque fois on s'est rendu compte
après coup que les choses ne se
passaient pas comme on quand je dis on
c'est la république c'est nous tous moi
même j'ai participé sous chirac haut
conseil à l'intégration enfin donc voilà
si on remonte un peu sur les va tout en
der année mon propos de tâtonner 1 ne
vise personne en particulier je m'inclus
là dedans on est sur un sujet complexe
donc c'est intéressant
première marque deuxième remarque hélas
hélas c'est la question avant la
question juste une deuxième remarque
très brève
c'est vrai que à travers à la fois nos
propres échange de membres de la
commission denquête et à travers les
auditions que nous avons tout d'ailleurs
où la plupart très intéressante
apparaissent ce hit us entre ceux et
celles qui considèrent que
il ya la république crème de la
république il n'y a pas lieu de se poser
la question d'une organisation c'est pas
le sujet que rentrer là dedans c'est
déjà commencer à et ceux qui considèrent
objectivement je fais partie de cette
catégorie que je reprends les propos de
la rapporteure il ya déjà ce qu'il a dit
sur la représentation etc on ne peut
être que d'accord mais à partir de là il
ya des religions en france qui ont une
organisation et il fut un temps tout au
long de notre histoire je pense comme ça
ça me vient à l'esprit napoléon avec les
juifs de france etc
il ya un moment où le pouvoir temporel
alors non pas à napoléon c'est un autre
moment métaux au minimum dans un
dialogue sur le regard qu'on peut porter
sur cette organisation est là ma
question est là est la suivante votre
association vont très bien c'est fort
intéressant on voit bien que c'est une
démarche qui est encore en devenir est
ce que dans votre esprit vous avez
vocation à être s'ils ont un partenaire
du moins une voix des sachants des gens
qui ont des choses à dire au delà de
votre vocation que vous avez rappelé je
n'y reviens pas sur la question de la
structuration de l'islam de france même
évidemment par d'autres que vous qui
peut-être en gros un jour la suite de ce
qu'ils se tapent tonnes à l'heure
actuelle ce niveau là où ou donc comment
vous positionnez-vous là-dessus ce que
vous positionner de manière complètement
extérieur à sa hauteur nous on a notre
part de business pour la bonne cause on
a également un
notre dimension cultuelle at
intellectuelle etc ou est-ce que nous
avons aussi moi j'ai vu en 2016 le
travail que vous avez fait pour la
fondation pour l'institut montaigne j'ai
trouvé fort intéressant j'étais pas
d'accord avec tout et j'ai trouvé fort
intéressant c'est ça marquait une étape
il ya eu d'autres rapports fondapol etc
et les choses qui portaient parfois un
peu dans tous les sens je perds pas ton
à paul je parle en général et la bon ça
a marqué une étape
forcément on ne peut pas imaginer que
vous n'ayez pas aujourd'hui quelques
idées sur ce que pourrait être demain
l'organisation de l'islam de france en
excusant d'avoir été un tout petit peu
plus long que je le souhaitais part oui
alors je je je le redis je pense est
très important toutes les religions en
france sont organisées toutes les
religions sont financés de façon
transparente
il ya même des religions qui par exemple
c'est le cas du consistoire central du
judaïsme français utilisent le cacher
comme un instrument central de
financement en même temps que les dons
nous ce qu'on veut faire c'est pas très
différent c'est même à peu près
exactement la même chose
bon il se trouve qu'il ya d'autres
sujets de consommation lié à la religion
dans la religion musulmane
il ya le halal on peut discuter du halal
vous avez reçu madame bergeaud blackler
on peut discuter de l'utilisation qui
est faite l'invention du traditions etc
on peut aussi constater on déplore on le
déplore part ça c'est pas mon sujet que
c'est devenu une activité économique qui
est une activité économique importante
il ya la question du pèlerinage qui est
très mal organisé avec des abus et c'est
donc avoir un régulateur qui contribue à
structurer l'organisation du culte par
le financement je pense que c'est
essentiel et je pense pardon que c'est
ce que font tous les autres cultes le
denier du culte étant dans l'église
catholique une façon d'organiser et de
financer
ensuite la vocation de la mif n'est pas
de dire la théologie la vocation de la
mif
elle est à la fois ambitieuse et modeste
c'est un rouage dans un système qu'il
faut réussir à mettre en place avec une
représentation du culte en l'occurrence
des mosquées
beaucoup de questions qui sont liées aux
mosquées et puis de l'autre côté des
questions qui sont des questions
religieuses les questions théologiques
qui ont vocation à être traités par des
religieux et des théologiens
aujourd'hui on a tout mélangé au sein du
cfcm on a mélangé le les questions
d'organisation du culte les questions
financières et les questions
théologiques
je crois que c'est mal fait je pense ya
une nouvelle direction au cfcm une
nouvelle direction la mosquée de paris
qui ont je pense de bonnes intentions
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'islam a besoin
de france a besoin de séparer les ordres
un ordre cultuelle un ordre financier un
ordre théologique
plus tard peut-être que tout ça sera
réunie sous le même toit
comme c'est le cas avec le consistoire
central tant mieux aujourd'hui
il faut séparer les ordres et notamment
sur le plan des activités économiques
séparer les opérateurs économiques du
régulateur
on essaye mais aussi un grand bocal
théâtre des hommes et des femmes de
bonne volonté et vous avez le marché
c'est une question qui est difficile un
problème complexe
c'est complexe pascal de l'humanité
parce qu'il ya de l'humain dedans en
marketing dit le critère le plus
important et le plus important que
l'ensemble des critères notre centre de
keita le plus important c'est de
comprendre que c'est une question
française qui est qui doit être réglé
par tous les français ça n'est pas qu'un
élément mais je ne m'en pure qui vous
l'a vu tout effet bien compris vous avez
fait référence à l'espérance quand on
n'oublie pas que c'est une et 3,28
théologales parce quand même voilà vous
venez donc assisté à l'audition du
président de l'amif l'association
musulmane pour un islam de france
hakim el karoui a dit ne pas vouloir
répondre aux accusations de non
représentativité adressées à l'encontre
de son association il a tenté
d'expliquer le projet de son association
un projet qui vise notamment selon lui à
mieux structurer la religion musulmane
en france
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
rester avec mon l'information politique
continue sur public sénat
[Musique]